to its natural end.
So by having death as a part
of the cultural and social fabric of life,
people's everyday decisions about their health
and healthcare are affected.
The patriarch of my husband's maternal clan,
Nenet Katcha,
is now approaching the age of 100, as far as we can tell.
And there are increasing signs
that he is about to depart on his own journey for Puya.
And his death will be greatly mourned.
But I know that my husband's family
looks forward to the moment
when they can ritually display
what his remarkable presence has meant to their lives,
when they can ritually recount
his life's narrative,
weaving his story
into the history of their community.
His story is their story.
His funeral songs will sing them a song about themselves.
And it's a story that has no discernible beginning,
no foreseeable end.
It's a story that goes on
long after his body no longer does.
People ask me if I'm frightened or repulsed
by participating in a culture
where the physical manifestations of death
greet us at every turn.
But I see something profoundly transformative
in experiencing death as a social process
and not just a biological one.
In reality, the relationship between the living and the dead
has its own drama in the U.S. healthcare system,
where decisions about how long to stretch
the thread of life are made based on our emotional
and social ties with the people around us,
not just on medicine's ability to prolong life.
We, like the Torajans,
base our decisions about life
on the meanings and the definitions
that we ascribe to death.
So I'm not suggesting that anyone in this audience
should run out and adopt the traditions
of the Torajans.
It might be a little bit difficult
to put into play in the United States.
But I want to ask what we can gain
from seeing physical death not only as a biological process
but as part of the greater human story.
What would it be like to look on
the expired human form with love
because it's so intimately a part of who we all are?
If we could expand our definition of death
to encompass life,
we could experience death as part of life
and perhaps face death
with something other than fear.
Perhaps one of the answers to the challenges
that are facing the U.S. healthcare system,
particularly in the end-of-life care,
is as simple as a shift in perspective,
and the shift in perspective in this case
would be to look at the social life of every death.
It might help us recognize that the way we limit
our conversation about death
to something that's medical or biological
is reflective of a larger culture that we all share
of avoiding death, being afraid of talking about it.
If we could entertain and value
other kinds of knowledge about life,
including other definitions of death,
it has the potential to change the discussions
that we have about the end of life.
It could change the way that we die,
but more importantly,
it could transform the way that we live.
(Applause)